foreign  [Music]  I've come to bring the transparency to  this tragedy  before he fell into darkness he was much  loved by everyone fell into darkness  you saw my brother kill himself The Eyes  Of God are on us all  this was the ultimate confessional the  nuts they stand here and for every sin  committed they take a step back the more  steps they took they fell to their death  God caught them  [Music]  we live a discipline  cleansed purified  [Music]  where are my clothes mother says we must  first remove the filth from them  science what is it you seek  my brother was badly hurt before he fell  I think he discovered something that he  was afraid of  do you need help child  something for you  Church of Truth  I come here when I have dark thoughts  I think I might be a really bad person  [Music]  what is it that you think you know  don't be scared  there's got one God  foreign